nos dicen que la fórmula para convertir
a celsius una temperatura en fahrenheit
es los grados celsius o ce es igual a 5
novenos que multiplica los grados
fahrenheit menos 32 describe la fórmula
resolviendo para fahrenheit y como
mencioné ésta se son los grados celsius
la temperatura en grados celsius
mientras que la f es la temperatura en
grados fahrenheit fahrenheit así es que
esta es una fórmula que nos da ce en
términos de f y nos piden resolverla
para encontrar efe en términos de c para
empezar escribamos la fórmula que es
igual a 5 novenos que multiplica a efe
menos 32 y queremos despejar efe así es
que lo primero que vamos a hacer es
deshacernos de este 5 novenos del lado
derecho de la ecuación para que tan sólo
nos quede efe - 32 y la manera más fácil
de hacer esto es multiplicar ambos lados
de la ecuación por el recíproco de 5
novenos hagamos eso entonces voy a
multiplicar el lado derecho por 9
quintos voy a ponerlo aquí
quede un poco apretado y recuerda que lo
que hacemos del lado derecho hay que
hacerlo también del lado izquierdo así
es que multiplicamos el lado izquierdo
también por 9 quintos que obtenemos
entonces del lado izquierdo nos queda 9
quintos que multiplica a celsius oa
grados celsius y esto es igual a todo
esto lo hicimos para cancelar 9 quintos
con 5 novenos estos 9 se cancelan estos
5 se cancelan el coeficiente se hace 1 y
del lado derecho nos queda grados
fahrenheit menos 32
efe menos 32 ya no es necesario poner el
paréntesis pues es el único término que
queda del lado derecho como queremos
resolver para efe para grados fahrenheit
vamos a deshacernos de ese menos 32 del
lado derecho la manera más fácil que
conozco de hacer esto es sumar 32 a
ambos lados de la ecuación sumar 32 a
ambos lados de la ecuación
así es que del lado izquierdo tenemos 9
quintos de grados celsius más 30 y 29
quintos de grados celsius
y eso es igual a menos 32 y 32 se
cancelan por eso hicimos ese sumar 32 a
ambos lados de la ecuación
así es que esto va a ser igual a efe y
ya hemos terminado hemos descrito esta
fórmula que tenemos aquí arriba para
grados fahrenheit aquí tenemos la
expresión donde grados fahrenheit está
en términos de grados celsius